Ladies and gentlemen, I welcome you
to our lecture on
Martin Heidegger
Heidegger asked the very big, genuinely
philosophical question: what is
the meaning of being, what is the meaning of
life and holier?
With his analysis of existence, he is undoubtedly one of the
most important thinkers of the West
In 1927, in the Weimar Republic,
he published and wrote his main work, Being and Time,
and I'll tell
him honestly, when I
got my hands on this book as a young student, I could
n't put it down, it
sucked me into a whirlpool because it
describes sacred things  the deepest
structures of our life our
own being there and he one structure
after the other and so they all here
in the hall and I and also everyone outside
all people if holy is right
have
common structural characteristics
our whole world perception our
behavior our thinking and feeling
make out
and holier calls these
basic human structures
these common characteristics that
determine our life
existentials I have already listed them for you here
a bit
so that it does not remain so abstract
I anticipate an existential a
bit the concern of the concern
character of  Dasein would be such a
structure that we all have and that we
cannot discard either, because
every human being has this deeply
underlying structure that he
has to worry about his life, that he has to manage his life
somehow,
find his way around in the world and give life a
direction  he does it through
big and small decisions and that
of course looks very different for each of us
one
takes the job the
other the other one gets married the other
doesn't but that they each
have to take care of their own lives that
's a structure  which we can't
betray and now he says something
interesting on the occasion,
these many small, big
decisions that we make in life to
give life a direction
can also be wrong and we ca
n't actually live in an inauthentic mode of life that actually doesn't bother us  corresponding there are authenticity
and inauthenticity as possibilities of
our existence and we quickly run the
risk of coming into this mode of the anonymous through the man through
society through all the
influences
and then leading a life
which maybe not at all our
determinations through the big question that
arises  for you and for me for all of us
is of course now how do I find
my destiny how do I find my
authenticity am I in the
authenticity that you will experience today
good
so holier is yes together with sandre
the forefather of the philosophy of existence he
himself but says no  he would not
be an existential philosopher he would be a fundamental
ontologist this work is fundamental
ontology what does he mean by that again
[music]
ontology is the study of being and you
can explain it most simply
with biology BIOS loosely
so loosely logic is called the theory
the theory of  Life or sociology who
the science of society or
zoology the science of the animal world and
so on these are all individual
anthologies Geology GEOS looses
the science of the earth individual ontology
that all try to explain a
part of being
transparent to explain the sense
of regularity  find and
understand and the saint says now
but all these individual anthologies presuppose
something
fundamental, something fundamental
that has not been asked at all,
namely the condition of the
possibility that you understand being at all,
not what these sub-areas have for a
meaning but he asks about the
meaning  from being at all about the meaning
of life I have my
first quote right away and so it is always necessary
to ask questions about the meaning of being
in order to work on and answer this question about the meaning of
life,
so we must first of all
see who  is then the questioner
who asks such a question and that
is only the human being and in this is what
the human being says we keep saying
sentences with is the weather is nice
that is a wonderful world or
capitalism is unfair and must be
fought in a revolutionary way  these are
the already expressing an
understanding of being in these individual actual
sentences there has always been a small
understanding of being and that is why he says
we must first research the human being
as the one who asks the question that is
why he can say
elaborating the question of being means
making a
being transparent  of the questioner in his being
so elaborating the question names are
of life means making transparent
the questioner so the human being in
his being because we are the questions
a stone doesn't ask
and
then continues and says these
beings that we are ourselves and that
among other things, the being has the possibility of
questioning, we understand terminologically as being there
so these enemies that we
humans are ourselves he calls being there
because only humans have the
possibility as questioners in the world
and he now calls it being there that
is a purely terminological
definition and then comes his sentence,
a beautiful central sentence from Heidegger
that there is being that is
about this in its being
Whole holy
that would be a single jargon of
actuality so a Sharon but it's
not quite true holy has like
by the way each one I also
appreciate as you know
used its own language to
say what he wanted to say and this sentence
is basically  yes also quite understandable
that being there we already know that
being there is what is beings what can ask
so the human being
is a being in his being about this
itself I translate it now in a
very positive way that is a very
simple substitute maybe I will do
I'm translating too easily now
holy specialists listen please just
step away man is a living being
whose life is about this life you
understand and it becomes
understandable man is a
living being whose life is
about his own life  The
stone is not about its own life,
I think so, but the people
are,
and if we are now researching the human being
and he is doing that now, then
we need a new method, namely
phenomenology, it got his
teacher Husal from it because the classic
scientific method  does
n't work at all because
an experimental arrangement is made and
a catalog of questions is set up and it
is then placed over the object
and then of course we
only get the answers that are already in the question -
something else is
not asked at all and about the
people  to explore as a sense and being
understanding being
we need another method the
phenomenology and he describes what
I shows as it
shows from himself let see from himself
so he says we have to let the
phenomena exist as they do
show a lot of themselves and are
not allowed to put our grid over it right away
I can unfortunately no longer
elaborate on this is the phenomenology but
he actually achieved amazing results with this new
method
a first one I want to present to you right away
it is at the same time
a first existential namely that  to
be in the world because when we
take a phenomenological look at people, it is not the case that we
are first subjects and then look at the world,
the world is outside, here
we are and then at some point the world comes
into us because we recognize the world
that way  is not it says the
holy phenomenologically it is
simultaneously as soon as we
open our eyes we are in the world we are
when we open in the room in the room we
smell we are simultaneously
with the world it is not that we
are subjects first and then  approaching the world
this classic subject-object
separation that e.g. the card and
Manuel can still do it does
n't exist phenomenologically, you know who can, the
subject is the human being and he puts his 12
categories and the a priori
visual forms over space and time  the
object and then comes to a
realization and holy said no it
is at the same time we are one being in the
world
and not only that he also accuses Kant and
others that they
have forgotten something fundamental how
people approach the world, namely we are
too  and that would be the next
existential always in any
condition we are always
in a mood and it is not so
insignificant now you can say yes the
mood is absolutely irrelevant for the knowledge
but it is not so
sacred says in focusing on and
grasping that being there does not
first get out of its inner blockage in
which it is initially encapsulated, but
in its primary way of being it is
always already outside with an
encountering being in the
world that has already been discovered and which
we are therefore in sight of
always been in the world that
still refers to being in the
world and the state of mind is
that we
Europeans have always been in the world
and in a very specific
mood the mood also shapes our
knowledge he says moods
spoiled  be able to change and be able to change
only says that being there has always
been in the right mood so you say he goes
through the world with rose-colored glasses
and sees everything wonderfully in the most
beautiful bright colors or you
say he sees everything gray in gray because he is
always in a depressed mood  is and
it can also be you are in a
wonderful mood and all of a sudden
it turns into the depressed mood
in children quite often but it is never the case
that we don't have a mood so
moods are always there or
mood you can
quickly times here now  do the test for examples
I will now give in 5 seconds
try not to be in the mood
and not have any feelings
and difficult or most of you will
probably have thought what
does the speaker want from this funny
question and even if they but also if
You think that if she goes like that yes
funny situation how do I get
out of my mental state then you have
a mood again you understand
and think yes the funny speaker so
you are always in some mood
even if you try to meditate
it is not mood  they never come
out completely that's why it's the second
existential why is the mood or
the mood important at all
because it influences our perception
I'll show you here quite simply
that it's the same tree the lumberjack
takes the tree and the father with the
child and the  The dog also notices the tree,
but the tree is perceived differently due to the
different moods,
so the
father shows the daughter these wonderful blossoms from the
apple tree
and is in the wonderful,
beautiful summer mood blue sky and
the lumberjack has to cut down the tree because
the road is widened and  sees it
as work and also looks very
worried so you see that the same
tree but it will be completely different
now imagine a
couple of lovers lying under the tree and
looking up at how slowly the branches are swaying in the
sky they are taking the tree  It
was different again, so the mood
also leads to a different
perception and what we can see here in the
little picture
the lumberjack looks a bit
worried now, but the father is also worried,
so the worry structure of being there that
I have already indicated before this
structure of care
is an existential of course because
the lumberjack
may now be specifically concerned that he thinks
a nice tree stupid
road I have to cut down or he is
worried if he is still working with the ax
and knows soon the ones with the
chainsaws might be going to cut him down  Job costs
maybe he is also worried about something
completely different but the concern in itself
we always have the concern structure and
the father is concerned and maybe wants
the child to interact with nature
and appreciate nature
and said now in the directed
caring to be looking out for something that is
clear to the care the respective world
so everyone is also concerned about something
else so
and in our care we are always looking out for
something so a good
school education a good education
we care about the future we  for
example we worry about yes we
want to think about what do we want to study or do
we want to do an apprenticeship
and so on and the concern is
omnipresent so for example
one even speaks of
old-age provision one also speaks of
health
precaution and holy means but with that
concern character of there should be
existential no single concrete
concern not the sum of all worries
but
the basic structure that we have to
worry you know
this halogen-like song good morning
dear worries are you there again
he doesn't mean the individual  I do
n't worry either I hum the song
but the structure that we can't do anything
else so to design ourselves for the future
and then said this
beautiful sentence that being there is
always anticipating him in his being why
we humans are always in our
present  first of all because we
think about the future we design for the future
it is and it is even
an existential that we
can and must design ourselves we must and
can design ourselves
and
that we have no choice so a
young person is probably even
more  in the design mode because he has to
think a lot about where he wants to go
or learn French or English
or this and that but also in old
age in old age we also have to
constantly give direction to our existence
make small and big decisions
and that's why he says  that being there is
as long as it is drafting but we wo
n't come out as long as we are we
are drafting interesting me
now but that he also says we ca
n't merge into the present that does
n't work so all the wheel of fortune
books where it says live in the moment
carpe  Attempts
to open up at the moment are only possible sporadically, if
at all, because ultimately
this structure is and can be deceived that
we are designing
on the basis of the way of being that was constituted by
the existential back then through the
existential of the design,
existence is constantly more than it
actually is  yes, how does he mean that
why is our existence constantly more than
it actually is
I had a friend who has I
still had
studied medicine and these
medical students are not just
medical students who are
already there more than at the moment they
see each other  as future doctors and
they also go through all illnesses, he
always felt it inside himself whenever he learned a new illness
and thought yes, I
probably did because he
got to know all the symptoms and they are more
than they are
but I think a better example is the
athlete in training an athlete who is training for the
Olympics he is not just
an athlete because he sees that he
designs it again and again during the design he
designs himself for the future
already as a winner he has to otherwise
he wouldn't be able to  find the energy
to go to your limit every day
and beyond that you can
only do that because he already sees himself on the
podium because he
has the ambition to
become an Olympic champion he is already a winner before
he has won so that will be there
all the time  more than it is at the moment
because we are planning for the future
and now
an interesting turning point like the
turning point is not really coming, but now he thinks
things through to the end he says that
being there is as long as it is designing and
there  something is already casting its shadow
ahead namely death and he says as something
thrown into the world to be is that being there
already answers about his death
being to his death dies in fact
constantly
why is existence ever already
about its death answers that
actually  it is clear that being there
dies it is also clear
the moment we are there as thrown
he speaks of the thrown design by the way
because in our life we ​​have
the design character that we
design for the future but we are
not asked before birth whether  we
now want to come into the world as a stone as a table
or as a plant or as a
human being but we come into the world as a
projecting one and are thrown into the world
therefore we are a projected
project but at the same time as being
thrown into the world we will
also be thrown into the  Death thrown in because
each of us dies so far the
scientists haven't invented what
in any way
keeps the cells eternally renewed and young we
actually die that's what holy means
when he says that being there
actually dies but why do we keep dying
why do we keep dying
we  die constantly because being unto
death so he says being there is being
unto death because of course we are
constantly approaching death every day or every
evening it's already evening again
every evening we are a day
poorer tonight so we are again
approaching this point in time it's
actually all pretty banal
now it's coming but how do we deal with it
and this is where it's getting more difficult how do
we deal with the fact that our existence is a
being unto death first of all he says
very dryly the end of the in  The
being of the world is death and how can we
deal with this fact and the
saint says that we are usually very
strongly involved in the existential of being
and there is a risk
that we fall into the mode of the anonymous man,
that is to say  just do what
everyone else does, what you do we
believe that we decide and
plan our lives in reality,
but we only fulfill a few
requirements and conveniently do what
you do and the
ideal images, well, at Heiliger there were
n’t any  Social media and nothing but
we don't care about advertising Society
and the ideal images that
exist in society, they aren't
really laid down anywhere, yes, but they
exist in social media in
advertising on television in the cinema in
society, we also get them
from parents  through school through
beer mugs and
it makes sense for us that we
behave and give direction to our lives the way one
gives life the same direction that is the danger
of falling into the anonymous man with his
we are all because the judgment of
is always important to others
we can't get out of it but the man's that
's a modality and he says now
it's about dealing with death there
says the man says death will certainly come
but not for the time being with this one
but the man speaks to the  Death the
certainty from this point on is
postponed to a later date,
with reference to the
so-called general discretion, i.e. that
we actually die, everyone says yes, yes,
that’s true, but we postpone it,
we suppressing children for children is
not a problem anyway, but also suppresses young people
in old age represses what
and according to general judgment man says
one actually gets erm so and so old
it's about that it's still a long way away I
looked it up according to
general judgment is the
average life expectancy according to
the current mortality tables that's what they say they
do  Statisticians for
newborn girls are currently
83.4 years and for boys
78.6 years and it means you
still have a lot of time and
of course those who
are older have a certain age,
you will get even older, but it doesn’t matter
anyway we just tell ourselves we are
yes it's still funny yes we're still
funny you don't want to put it that way, of course, yes
I do
n't, I don't make it clear either and
the saint now says that yes
this man you still have time the
general discretion says I still have
a lot of time this man  does not allow the courage to
fear death
and that is bad Heidegger recommends
my that is bad is a
way of course to deal with it
but he recommends us exactly the
opposite he says we have to actively
anticipate our death anticipate I brought
it with me in anticipate  reveals
the forlornness of existence in which one is
oneself and brings it for the possibility of
being oneself so in anticipation of
our death if we really
look at it and say okay how
much longer do I actually have
then we have the possibility when we  come
back to
design differently and in fact there are
people who design themselves too big who
have an amazing project and at the
end of their lives or even when they are old you have
the feeling that I have not achieved anything I
have failed and vice versa you can
also design yourself too small and
then have the feeling I've
spread my whole life and frittered it away
by designing ourselves towards death
we get more substance into
our lives but it gets even more radical
that's actually an aspect of life yes
he is now going on with that man he
says  we enjoy and have fun as
one enjoys we read and judge
about literature and art as one sees
and judges but we also withdraw from the
crowd as one
withdraws we find what one hears
in the outrageous
and this way of life is very
comfortable though  he says there is a
great danger that we live an inauthentic mode of
our existence and not our
destiny and our authenticity
because we allow ourselves to be controlled too much by the
social imperatives
and if we ask ourselves then
we say no no no that's me and holy
hat  also in the being and time also
these data with this wonderful sentence in it
that we the there his often says
loudest I am it when it
is not itself so there is a danger
and he says this indiscriminate being taken away
by nobody by nobody he says
because my is based on
everything and nobody there is also
a saying in the vernacular yes everything and
nothing is based on everything and
then nobody that's why he can say
this to be taken along by nobody where
by itself being there
can only be entangled in inauthenticity
be undone in the shape that
I bring the being there specifically from the
lostness in the man back to
himself
so the being there has to specifically
bring itself back from the lostness in the
man to himself but how is that supposed to
work and he himself says it
really is  difficult if you say your
whole life or over a longer period of time he
says, by the way, we all have phases in
life where we only let ourselves be controlled by men,
so that affects us all and of
course it is difficult to
get out of it at all when you
have enjoyed this comfort for a long time
and  was in this rut ​​and he then says,
as a rule, that there is an
existential crisis, for example
a burnout, which simply
throws us out of the covers and
isolates us in a very
special mood in the mood of
fear the fear is not existential
although it is here  the fear
arises directly from the worry character of
existence and is a very important
basic mood in our life
because
alone in the fear lies the
possibility of an excellent
opening up because they are isolated and that's true
the fear is
isolated when they are in a state of fear
then the whole man sinks down it's
uninteresting how FC Bayern plays what's
on TV what the others
say they're brutal with
themselves so they're in a state of fear
and he says fear is a
direct part of
life for people and he
first of all, he then explains what he
means by fear, he often does
that he first says what he doesn't
understand by fear and then he says water
by fear, so he
first differentiates between fear
and fear and he defines it for us
it's pretty much the same but he
defines fear as fear
always has an object so we're afraid let's
say if a
mastiff growls at us then we're afraid
a dog will bite us that's a direct
object
or we're afraid of the
Diagnosis by the doctor that we
are positive and have some kind of illness or
we are also afraid of
global warming because of me that is relatively
concrete what we are afraid of the fear he
says is as a mood as a reason feeling
something which is strangely irrelevant
if you look at it phenomenologically
and he says exactly what the fear is
afraid of is not
to act from the inner worldly,
so the fear is
not afraid of
acting innerworldly in the
workplace or
all possible unreasonable
demands of life before that
the fear is not afraid that there
is  basically not where you
can say exactly before the fear starts to fear
and we also know from clinical
psychology that anxious patients
usually do not come with a phobia of
spiders or something like that, but rather anxious patients
have the problem that they
are afraid of life
and can no longer say anything  What
actually is the concrete cause of this
fear and that is what holier is now getting
to the bottom of and says if that
turns out to be what the fear is not about, that means the world as such,
then what the fear
is about is being in the world itself
this is now a phenomenological
observation
that I think actually
has substance, so in the fear of what the fear is
fears is really
not often not concrete
but that in the world its self and
we have already heard that we
cannot avoid it  the worrying
character of life life does
n't live by itself we have to worry about our
life design we have to live
life life has a purpose
character it doesn't live by itself
we have to take on this task again every morning
and when we're
scared  we are often afraid of
continuing to take on this task so it
is the fear of our own being in the
world namely of being
able to continue living our being in the world that
is the essence of fear that is very
difficult to understand this phenomenon
and it is  an important phenomenon of the
phenomenon of fear and Heidegger,
as always, has not given any examples in this book,
he shows us the
existential ones as structures but and
in this case the fear of the not and
that the fear lets everyone sink with worldly
references and that the fear
separates us and
throws us back on ourselves but he doesn't set an example
it's also always difficult but I
'll throw myself into the fold so
without revealing too much now but
I think we've all been afraid at times
it's not that
specific at all  but I'm sure
everyone here in the hall has had such
experiences, but phenomenologically you can
come close to what was meant more sacredly the ISA
beautiful day sun and I had
just broken up with my long-term
girlfriend yes and I was
already I would  say against a depressed
mood and then I thought to myself well
three or outside the sun is shining
blue sky wonderful and I just
moved to the Isar then and then
I thought to myself go out into the sun
then you'll feel better then
I'll go  out there and you see the many
people along the Isar,
somehow I didn't feel any better
despite the sun and then I look and then
I see lots of couples
and then I thought to myself, yes, I'll
actually be pretty alone then  If
I look further then I see young people
sitting in the beer box
with a nice little beer and you know
a fire and uh somehow even
more alone there
are others who now
run around like lone wolves just like me and actually have  I
saw some who were also alone but they
were out and about with their dog, I did
n't even have a dog
and then yes, now that I'm
laughing afterwards, I also laugh, but the problem was that
I then actually fell into total
self-pity, so I
always felt sorry for myself  felt more than such a completely
poor lonely one
and then, interestingly enough,
I somehow somehow reached a second
dimension, a second level
and I had to get out of there,
I had to get out of there, right, and
sat under the tree and noticed there
people suddenly left and then
I had a feeling of complete
futility I thought to myself what else is that
supposed to know what I'm
still here there was really a total
emptiness inside me I failed a bit
and then
at some point I got back into the  Basically achieved
and then on my own I felt
even better after that so
I was determined again yes well that's
just now and such experiences of fear
just to show that
the world with the world actually disappears
it's no longer there at some point  and there
is thrown back on himself on
his own creation of meaning that does
not yet describe exactly what holier
describes holier radicalized here namely
now but it shows the
approach how the basic condition of
fear can set in he says that
nothing before that brings fear reveals
the nothingness that
basically determines being
there, i.e. that nothing brings the fear of it,
reveals the nothingness that
determines our existence in its bottom, more
holy, was also insulted as a nihelist
and an atheist because he
says yes here when we are suddenly isolated on ourselves
in the mode of fear in this in this
deep mood of fear existence reveals to us our
own nothingness
our life essentially is in us
there is nothing that says
you should live yes it's not that
we eventually come to such a ground
and there is  then what says yes love
live but first of all there is not
by the way also the fear is the
dizziness of freedom because the more deeply you
look into yourself in the fear
the less there is there you can
get dizzy in a literal
sense and
[music]
believers  People, for example, when they
say there might be another
voice that tells you you're
not allowed to quote yourself, e.g. you have to
take charge of your life again in the face of
nothingness, they might still hear this
voice if they know yes,
suicide is a mortal sin and up to the middle
of the 19th century, the
suicides were not buried in wide ground
but outside of the cemetery
and
the Christian may be lucky enough to
hear you or the [ __ ] but
holier says they can also
have problems because
the walls in the positive he says
reveals the fear in existence  the freedom
to choose and seize oneself
the freedom to choose and
seize oneself and that is now the
positive side of fear we can
then actually not put ourselves firmly into this
and seize ourselves again
and say I carry on who
has lived through it  is different is
different again because he has more strength again
many burnout patients
even describe that after the burnout where
everything collapsed mostly the
job mostly also in private life
everything collapses so there it often comes at
once and all with worldly
references  are gone they are isolated
and they no longer manage
to take on the task of life so
it's not like they say my
break from work they
collapse they can't make it anymore and
are isolated and when they do manage to get out of
the  emerge from a crisis
then
they often even live a changed
life sometimes find their
authenticity and do things
differently and give life a different
direction that works
well again and the interesting thing is now
I mean this fear it's really
intense I had one too
An acquaintance who was in the sect and
then left and that was very
difficult for me, it was an eternal back and forth
because these sects also have
something positive, otherwise
people won’t be in there, there is an
incredible sense of solidarity,
mutual confirmation and he knew
he loses it all so he had to get
out of there and he has it difficult too yes
and by the way what else did I want to
tell you the statisticians I want to
try again Everybody thinks of suicide
a few times in their life that
doesn’t mean that we’re there forever  in
the depression are about to
think about suicide but as a thought
that you actually think there is this
possibility that everyone is doing well
and now something else is coming up so if we
read the book then I thought yes
being there is essentially based on
this absolute freedom in the face of
nothingness to decide for its
authenticity but
suddenly comes yes we are not
completely alone there is actually a
quiet call then thought where does
this call come from now and it gets exciting because I
thought who is this caller supposed to
be because  he just said
the core in us is nothing we create
our core only through our design
and our decision and he calls that
the call of conscience what calls the
conscience of the called too strictly
speaking does not
the call says nothing gives no
information about  World events has nothing
to tell least of all who strives
to open up a soliloquy in the person called nothing is called to the person called
but it is
called to himself that means
being able to be on his own so this
call of conscience says don't do this
or that or quit the job  it is
also not a soliloquy that
we think how do I have to change my life
that is just a soft call that
calls us back to our existence or as
first formulated it is a call we are
called to ourselves we are already
called to carry on I  I think
with tropenhauer I would say there
is a very will to live that is already there
so we are called but who is
the Hofer who writes literally who is
the caller who is calling us there and then
said if that was
his answer if it
was there than  Concern about being it calls out
of the uncanniness
to be itself so this worry
character is there that we have
always been concerned about our lives anyway it
also comes into play in the mode of fear
in this basic mood of fear
it comes into play  and says
and calls us into our existence he calls
us that is, so to speak, the call of
conscience that's why he can say the call
comes from me and yet about me because
being there calls itself into life
well the conscience reveals itself
ultimately as a call  the concern of the
callers is that being there
can be scary about being yes and
each of us has the chance
to hear this call because being there is listening to
its own possibility
of existence and now we are
with authenticity and inauthenticity
because we have the possibility in
to choose this basic mood of fear and self
and thereby to
find our authenticity therefore does
not say what then in detail
constitutes this authenticity
in his late work, but he also added
that in a mood of
serenity even of boredom
the environment that recedes with the world  and
here too we come before the inner emptiness
and cannot redesign ourselves in
this again, we also have
a chance to get into the authenticity there too,
his summary is
that being there has and that existence also has an
existential character of possibility, of
course  either I
quote the time here that being there
always understands itself from its
existence a possibility is itself
or not is to be itself
existence is decided in the way of
grasping or missing only by the
respective existence itself
so we ourselves
ultimately decide and that's why
we can of course
repress fear we can repress any state of fear
we can also
repress death we can repress the
holy but in the run-up to death we recommend that we
keep having this experience of fear and
try to bring what is really being to
reality  Now
I come to the last, to the last existential
guilt because being there consists of
big and small decisions
and we constantly
give the facilities we can
change direction when we
notice we are accountants have become
heartbroken and want, I don't know,
architects  we can definitely
start again and ready
when we start studying we
no longer see ourselves as accountants but
because being there is already ahead of ourselves
as future architects, so you
can always
change direction, but like us
we also decide we are to blame and about
guilt he now says something
interesting essentially guilty is that
being there not sometimes and then again
not guilty but we are
always guilty it is an existential
why are we not only
guilty sometimes when we have messed something up
and then  again not guilty
if you have done something well we are
always to blame because we constantly
make small and big decisions and
thereby become existentially guilty and
not before God nor before the
others but before our own existence we are responsible
for the life we ​​have not lived
They understand guilt because
we always make decisions and
the word decision says the saint
comes from divorce maybe even from
final divorce you know if you
become a pilot you can no longer
become a philosopher if you become a teacher
you can no longer become an athlete
so it doesn’t matter what profession  they seize
they decide and they eliminate
many other things in life, many
here in the room probably have
things like most people that you
thought maybe I should have
done, but
maybe we are also satisfied
with our decisions, but we are
always us  are responsible for what
we did irresponsible
for what we didn't do so
we're also responsible for the life we ​​didn't love because it's our fault
this existential guilt is
n't how should I say it's something really
big,
for example
tonight they are  now everyone here at
the sacred lecture and have
made themselves guilty because they
could have met friends now
they could have met family
go to the theater they could have gone to the opera
to a concert they could have
done something as God but they  have
decided they have x other
things that they could have done and
designed and
are here today and
they have to
take responsibility for that, even for very small
decisions, yes, I hope you do
n't feel very guilty that
you made that  but since that
ultimately means we will be
guilty of ourselves and of
course also of others for
being there and it is always important to him
that we should try
to lead an actual being there and he is
now doing something second in his
there  I also
brought you this one at the end Martin Heidegger
the technology and the turn
there is a very
interesting thesis I find there is still up he says
not only the individual but also entire
societies can come into an
inauthentic mode designs
entire societies entire nations and
he  says the huge problem nowadays is
that we are enslaved by the technology,
not oversleeping in the
sense that the technology also frees us
from many but the technology for
that it is not just a tool
but I'll do it in turn
first of all  technology is a
tool, so technical tools would be
a hammer, a saw, a drill
and so on and now the saint says,
but technology is also a
power plant, yes, the power plant with
its turbines and generators is a
man-made means to a man-made means
set purpose, even the
rocket plane, as well as the
high-frequency machine, are a means to an
end, so
technology
is always a means to an end, but
in this writing he then says that it
has long since outgrown it after
a few hundred years of the industrial
revolution, we're like that, we're
like that  technology gets used to the fact
that we perceive the world ourselves from a
technical point of view we
see the world technically that is and
he then explains that is now becoming a
problem technology says it is
not just a means to a
specific end technology is a
way
he experienced revealing revealing in Greek unconcealment
one could also say is a
way of searching for truth or
recognizing so today technology is
a way in which we recognize the world
we have now developed a
technical view of the world
and here we come  also under the
frame of technology there again such a
word of sacred language you have to get
used to but it already says
what we come under the frame of
technology about the technical perception
of the world we put nature like
the hunter puts the game or  as a
soft representative that sets the course
for the trains we set
nature agriculture is modernized
food industry the air is put on
the release of nitrogen the
soil on ores we put nature and
frame means the gathering of that
puts the people that
means challenges  that really in
a way of ordering as a stock to do without again
a real
holy I'll bring simple
examples again then we don't have to torture ourselves so much with the
language yes but under
frame he means the entirety
of this place that we get more and more under
control  gets and also degrades the human being
to a stock he himself
brings an example he says
already finds the word human resources so there
is working capital there is
physical
capital and there are human resources so
the human being is made into a stock
the physical capital is clear  if the
machines are the hall means of production
and the human being with all that he
brings in then knowing abilities are also
counted as a factor and is accepted
he also criticizes the medical devices
but that doesn't get it all right I
have the feeling maybe you can give your
own example  of the rack where the
rack of the technology is again
was only recently
via the cell phone, you can see it by the way
in the morning when people
go to the subway, right, that's a
rack that's how everything goes, that's
that  Frame of the technology they make us
shake hands but it goes
even further then I get a text message from
a friend who says yes let’s do
this and that next week man and I
was completely exhausted in the evening so there was a lot of
stress a lot going on I didn’t have it right away
answered thought yes i would answer the
next day i always had to think about it
the next morning i look in
then it says there you are dead yes and
why because i did not answer immediately
under the framework of modern
telecommunications by mobile phone you have to
reply to content within a certain period of time
because he  said he saw my tick
saw the tick
that I was open or read his text message
and still didn't
answer and then you're dead
that's the frame of the technology
you know and that's where the holy one already has what he
can do
and then  he says, for example, that
modern technology is
something that is right for him too, so the technology
of the problem is that it works, the
technology, the cars and everything about it
we are so gullible because we have
experience with the technology from the
car to the  electric toothbrush that
's right somewhere is works
and is relieving but
more holy tells us now modern
technology is driving towards the greatest possible
perfection and perfection is based on
the consistent predictability of
objects so we
no longer allow nature and objects to be present
and show ourselves how  they
generate themselves but we try
to calculate everything and this calculation
can have distributed consequences because this
calculability is often not correct and
I now have a nice example of
holier himself he was an opponent of nuclear power
he was an opponent of nuclear power back then
only had the first ones  Power plants
existed in his time and he was massively
opposed when he heard that the
half-life was 24 or 25,000 years
and said we ca
n't expect that from other generations and he
doesn't believe that it's calculable it was
calculated but a search was then
made for repositories  Gorleben and Asse and
it was then legally stipulated that
such a repository
had to be safe for a million years and had to be
able to store the radioactive substances. He got
upset because he said it could
n't be calculated and this
repository that was safe for a million years actually
didn't have it  works we see a
picture from the hate two here that was a
salt dome like Gorleben and
salt dome with the salt mine it was
of course a good idea to
store the radioactive waste in a salt dome at the bottom because the salt
shields it from what you say  the
geologists had quite
different opinions because
salt domes also migrate well then
it was researched and released and
designated as a repository and after 30
years we had the first water ingress
after 30 years although it was calculated for a
million years and
a decade later you then have it
Tried to seal the breach points again
and it was no longer
possible. In the meantime, 10,000
liters of water flow into the Asse every day and
are pumped out with their own
pumping stations and filled up in load power plants at the top,
which then tilt again
because if you pump the water to the same height,
it is not yet there  radioactive
meanwhile the barrels are eroded
below is a radioactive radiation
that nobody can get down there anymore and
now it was decided that the
aces get all these barrels out again
within the next ten
years until 2033
so from 2033 one should be ready for
that  you can get something out of there again
and because no one can go down,
you are now building this robot, the
so-called tripod with its three
legs, which can then go underneath and
get these barrels and the crazy thing is, but
now you need a second shaft where you can
bring it down, then you need it  over here
that it might
cost billions between four and
I don't know ten billions just to look for them
and once you have them upstairs
we don't know where to look
then the saint has said something right
they told you that mankind  enters
the age to which it gave the name
atomic age, so at that time
it was actually said in all the media
now it's going to the atomic age because there
was such optimism and people thought they
could calculate it and so
he writes a recently published one calculated for the
general public  the book is
titled we will live through atoms
the book has a foreword by
the Nobel Prize winner Otto Hahn and the
Minister of Defense Franz Josef
Strauss at the end of the
introduction the authors write that the
atomic age can therefore become a
hopeful happy age
an age in which we can live through
atoms  it depends on us
and holier says, however,
it depends on us and some
other things it depends on whether we
still think about it, whether we
want to think about it and if we can, well, and of course
he actually has that to a
certain extent  Wisely right that
something like this is no longer calculable how is
the technology always wants to calculate and what does
he mean by disability
so the thinking of the atomic physicist Otto
Hahn thinks he is senseless and if
we want to survive he says we have to
turn around that's why it says
here  the technology and the animals we have
to make a complete turn
and can no longer subject our entire
perception to the imperative of
technology what can we calculate
what can we demand from the ground what
and so on but we need a
contemplative thinking that is the meaning of
that  we need to look at the whole thing again
instead of becoming users
designs we need to be treasured we
need a whole new
attitude and we need a
contemplative thinking that no longer allows itself to be
enslaved by the technical
thoughts of the total use of
nature and said on this occasion
we should also get on the path
of contemplation, then we first have to
make a distinction that shows us the difference between
thinking that is merely calculating and
thinking that is contemplative, so
we finally have to make this distinction between thinking that is contemplative and thinking that is merely calculating
and he also has something comforting he
says but where there is danger the
savior grows also where the danger is there
the savior grows too Hölderlin had taken a quote
from Hölderlin
and it's not from him but heroes
and that's why he has it  taken over because he
says man is built in such a way that
when the danger is actually great and
he notices the consequences then
what often happens
in his spirit in his in his being in
the world he orients himself new he
gives things a new one with decisions
direction and here he may have
said something hopeful is
actually it is so that for the
first time in history we
now have a phase in which
humanity as a whole is becoming aware
that we now
have to act jointly and decisively if we can protect the
human species at all  wanting to preserve the planet
that has never existed
before, that a worldwide awareness
was generated in this regard, whether it will still
come in time, all that is
my other question, nobody can
decide, I summarize again, holier
asks the question of the meaning
of being after the meaning  of life then
said this question who asks this question
it is the human being it is human
existence that has to ask and who
cares about his life in his life the
human being is the questioner only
asks you the question about the meaning of being
so we have to  first of all, know the person
who asks this question, then
he looks at the being there and
says and works out these categories,
the being in the world, the state of mind, the
worry, the design, the
being to death, with his, the fear
has the possibility and the  It's
his fault, ladies and gentlemen,
because now he's asked the question about the
meaning of life, he's answered the question about
the meaning of life, he
doesn't have it, and in this book at the very
end, he asks the
question again and says well, he has
he did not answer it, but he created the basis
on which he might then be
able to answer the question and he
then promises that he will answer the question of meaning in a second
volume of fundamental ontology,
this second
volume he never wrote this second volume
and that means the question
remains  keep open
thanks
[applause]